I hope this means in your free time
you're gonna come guest anchor with me
soon Stephanie that would be fun to do
and you always want to have a back-up
occupation of my line of work but i'll
also be busiest executive chairman so
it's good to be on with you and corey
again all right well tell me what is
your new role going to be what's it
gonna be like day-to-day well the new
role will function in areas where the
next CEO Chuck wants me to focus on
probably around the areas of being
advisor to him on vision and strategy
watching him grow to be a great CEO
which I think he will be I'll be his
wingman in many areas like country
digitization which is the next frontier
Francisco and keperra our growth not for
one to two years but for ten years focus
a lot on key strategic partnerships key
customer relationships and speaking and
so bottom line is Chuck will be the CEO
he will make the decisions I will become
his wingman and it would be fun and I'm
really excited about this and I had my
best night's sleep in 20 years last
night I can only imagine John what was
it about Chuck you know you've got a
deep bench there there a couple of
people who were in the running for this
job what was it a particular about chuck
was it was that his sales expertise was
it operational matters I mean Cisco's
been through a lot of changes over a lot
of years when clicked in the last few
years well it's really exciting not the
board pick Chuck have my job was to get
several candidates ready their job was
to pick the person they wanted to run
over the next decade and for me to be
his advisor as we do that what was so
unique about chuck is let's look at the
results over the last 20 years we
literally have our stock up in terms of
total shareholder return over sixteen
hundred percent you have earnings per
share up over thirty three hundred
percent you look at what we've been able
to accomplish in terms of our business
momentum it's because we got these
market transitions right Chuck is world
class to take in vision and strategy and
executing off of it he's done that in
the commercial marketplace he's done
that an enterprise he's done it in
channels he also is very good
about aligning resources in the
collaborative style that still allows
him to move quickly so he builds great
teams he gets the results he's a perfect
cultural match and he's very technical
math major by background so explain to
me what does he need to do to really
help with Cisco's long-term growth
you've been in that seat for 20 years
mm-hmm well we're very pleased with our
long-term growth and Chuck articulated I
think very well yesterday he's pretty
comfortable the vision and strategy
we're winning in the market our
customers get that we were just with our
top channel partners last week both
Chuck and I and this is eighty-five
percent of our business so that flows
through channels they buy the vision and
strategy he would say these probably
going to make some tweaks to that where
he thinks we can improve on and I
absolutely agree with him he's an
execution machine getting these pieces
to work better together realigned
resources in terms of opportunities to
where the growth is then John were ties
areas like security and software then
what's the biggest piece of unfinished
business you're handing off to him that
he will attack the hill execute from the
get-go what's going to be exciting is we
have a chance to replay the information
age where Cisco's leadership in the
internet during the 90s powered our
growth changed our country changed every
business you're going to see an instant
replay with every country every city
every business become digital you either
change disrupt or you die you get left
behind Chuck will lead that and I think
he'll do a great job on it so he I met
during the information age he would
leave during the digital age John I've
watched you a skillfully negotiate
between both Republicans and Democrats
at cisco has sold so well to government
but I wonder when you look at your
future so many people in Silicon
Valley's with Carly Fiorina of course
jumps out into mine look at the world of
politics as an opportunity where they
want to have an impact is that something
that interests you well it does interest
me but I'm you've got a problem I'm a
moderate Republican who likes Democrats
and I like to work with both sides
technology needs to be agnostic what
interested me about government is our
country becoming a digital country we
are behind
Germany France UK China India on this
and it will power the next generation of
job creation economic well-being middle
class wealth increase etc I also like to
teach and you'll see me probably teach
in a number of areas and then probably
work with young company start-ups etc
helping them perhaps go public so that
along with tremendous attention to my
family well deserved attention after
doing this for 20 years is what's in my
future Carly Fiorina if she were to be
elected would you consider her a Silicon
Valley insider who's now in Washington I
think if we do our job right we make
each candidate over the next year and a
half very technology knowledgeable and
savvy and Silicon Valley has to be again
neutral in terms of one candidate or
another I think it's so important for
both the Republicans and Democrats to
focus on job creation getting our nation
back on track and whether it's a
Democratic president or a Republican
president I think you're going to see
them align with technology much as
President Clinton did back in the mid
90s where he powered 22 million jobs
created GDP and economic growth of the
average citizen over fifteen percent
that was powered in part by the Internet
age this digital age has the same up I
don't know Johnny so jobs to make sure
that each of the government's understand
you seem to know a lot of answers that
may be a political official would know
when the Senate seat in California John
that that might be a open pretty soon
right are you interested we argued at
candidly now I politics moves to smoke
slow for me and like I said earlier I
like Republicans and Democrats I just
like getting things done I'd be honored
to be an adviser to whichever president
wins and I enjoy very much interfacing
to the Democrats and Republicans which I
just did a couple weeks ago in a trip to
Washington well he goes back technology
will change this country I'm afraid if
you like getting things done a future in
politics isn't for you I can we just say
what a great job it is getting things
done for 20 years you know let's go
wiping the floor with all these
competitors
on chambers absolute all the credit what
a terrific job